[Applaudissements]
une unité qui présage un durcissement du
mouvement anti réforme des retraites
même si fo pétrolier a déposé un préavis
de grève depuis le 5 décembre 2019
ce secteur n'avait pas encore manifesté
sa position sur cette mobilisation des
représentants syndicaux de la sarraz de
quelques stations service et des
chauffeurs de camions-citerne disent
être prêts à s'engager dans la lutte
dans les jours qui viennent
quand il s'agit d'autres fêtes jeudi que
quel prof le salarié même comme les
petits jeunes qui étaient là les plus
les moins âgés ils se sentent intéressés
alors pourquoi pas nous les les aînés
ceux qui sont proches de la retraite
pourquoi est ce que vous ne voulez pas
utiliser une telle collaboration du
secteur pétrolier annonce des jours
noirs la distribution d'essence risque
d'être très perturbé et les désagréments
pourrait même s'étendre à des secteurs
clés les représentants syndicaux de la
sahara rappelle que le groupe pétrolier
alimente aussi anti gaz edf le port et
l'aéroport
lorsqu'on ce ring 1 assommé général on
saura les modalités de la grève
ça peut être les sens où les véhicules
mais ça peut être plus que ça pour le
moment on ne sait pas encore comment ça
va se passer parce qu'on doit définir
les modalités avec les collègues de
salles en assemblée générale
extraordinaire qui va se passer d où il
est très probablement dans durant le
week-end ou plus tard le dit
l'intersyndicale anti-réforme des
retraites dit vouloir frapper fort pour
avoir une résonance nationale
aucune date ne nous a été révélé mais
les perturbations sont à prévoir dans
les jours qui viennent